[Music]
on this Saturday night missiles in the
Middle East strikes across several
countries fueling fears of a larger
conflict as pressure mounts on the
Israeli Prime Minister over a two-state
solution tragedy on Lake
Ontario The Frigid frantic recovery
effort after a vehicle crashes through
the ice heading to New Hampshire the
Republican primary build as Nikki
Haley's Last Hope to stop Donald Trump
and we can't have a country in disarray
and a world on fire and go through four
more years of chaos plus smashing
stereotypes indigenous calgarians offer
a new Twist on old
westerns global national with far Asser
reporting tonight Jeff
simple good evening and thank you for
joining us today saw missile attacks
across the Middle East with strikes in
Lebanon Yemen and Iraq the latter
injuring some American troops at an
Airbase Iran is now blaming Israel for a
missile strike in Syria that it says
killed five members of its revolutionary
guard including the Force's intelligence
Chief in Syria tyon is now vowing
Revenge that escalation in violence is
fueling fears the war in Gaza could
spiral into a wider regional conflict
McKenzie gray has our top story
tonight while the conflict continues to
rage on in Gaza the political fight in
Israel has turned
personal protesters including family
members of the over 100 hostages camping
outside Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
netanyahu's house demanding a return of
their loved ones we know that you can
sign this deal and bring a about this
Victory to the all to all the citizens
of Israel just do it BB just do it bring
the hostages back home the latest ploy
to make that a reality asking for help
from the residents of Gaza directly the
Israeli military dropping leaflets in
conun with pictures of the
hostages but the IDF is usually dropping
bombs across the territory the military
releasing new footage of air strikes on
what they claim is Hamas terrorist
infrastructure
but those strikes aren't limited to Gaza
two people were killed in Lebanon when
an Israeli drone targeted a car and in
Syria where this strike in Damascus
killed at least five members of the
Iranian revolutionary guard including an
intelligence Chief according to Iranian
State tv the continued expansion of the
conflict concerning the United Nations
we need a quick end to the war in Gaza
we need humanitarian assistance and then
we need to develop a strategy that is is
not only and I know this is a tall order
but a strategy that do not only include
Israel Palestine but the broader region
a broader region including Yemen whose
houy Rebels have continued to attack
commercial ships including this Malta
flag and Greek owned bulk carrier
leading the US and UK to bomb houthi
targets including an anti-ship missile
today the strikes not deterring the
houthi political Council a member
warning commercial ships will continue
to be targeted until the war in Gaza
stops Canada help plan strikes against
the houthis and are considering
following in the footsteps of the
Americans and listing the organization
as a terrorist group according to the
public safety Minister's office McKenzie
gray Global News
Ottawa Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is pushing back against calls
for Palestinian statehood reiterating
that he will not compromise on full
Israeli security control over the entire
region his comments come after a
suggestion from US President Joe Biden
last night that a two-state solution is
not off the
table there are a number of types of
two-state solutions I think there's ways
in which this could
work Biden spoke with Netanyahu on
Friday for the first time in nearly a
month the countdown to the US
presidential election is on and after a
Monumental victory in the Iowa caucuses
Republican candidate Donald Trump is
eyeing a win in New Hampshire on Tuesday
despite the legal drama surrounding his
campaign polls and the party appear to
be lining up in his favor as Reggie
Chini explains Republicans are not the
only ones holding a primary election
this
week trying to close the gap between
first and second Tuesday's Republican
primary in New Hampshire will be the
best and possibly last chance for Nikki
Haley to remain a viable candidate in
this campaign what's really at stake for
New Hampshire is whether or not Nikki
Haley can really pull away but besting
Donald Trump is a reality that exists
for very few people Nikki is somebody
that puts America list on Friday Trump
secured an endorsement that deals a blow
to the Haley campaign we need Donald
Trump Tim Scott a senator appointed by
Haley during her time as Governor turned
his back on her and as the establishment
Falls in line Trump's nomination appears
to be a fate to comple a remarkable
scenario amid Trump's legal struggles
what you did is a terrible thing in this
newly released deposition footage from
his New York civil fraud trial and
agitated Trump pushed back on
accusations of overinflating his net
worth but neither civil nor criminal
charges have soured his support which
after his historic win in Iowa is
steadily growing he's really a populous
candidate um mobilizing people to on the
one side particip in politics that
probably never would meanwhile New
Hampshire Democrats will also hold a
primary on Tuesday albeit with a glaring
Omission President Joe Biden won't be on
the ballot he didn't register to run
after the state refused to seed the
rights to holding the first Democratic
primary to South Carolina it was all
designed to please one Congressman Jim
kurn from South Carolina who arguably is
the person most responsible for Joe
Biden getting the nomination in 2020
Biden supporters are now scrambling to
put together a right-in campaign in New
Hampshire to avoid a poor showing and
provide fuel for Republicans who claim
Biden to be a weak candidate Reggie
Chini Global News
Washington Donald Trump I invite you to
Ukraine to K so if you can stop the war
during 24 hours Ukrainian President
Vladimir zalinski responding to Donald
Trump's claim that if reelected he could
stop the war in Ukraine within 20 2 4
hours zalinsky described that rhetoric
as very dangerous noting the lack of
details in Trump's plan the Republican
front runner has repeatedly claimed he
could negotiate an end to the war
because of his relationships with
leaders on both sides February will Mark
two years since Russia's fullscale
Invasion police say an 18-year-old man
has died after his vehicle crashed in
Toronto's
Harbor it took Crews several hours to
pull the Jeep out of the icy water no
one was found inside but nearly 5 hours
after the crash officials say the driver
was recovered from the water and
transported to hospital he was later
pronounced dead police say the vehicle
was sent off the road into the water
after it lost control and hit another
vehicle early this morning the other
driver was also taken to
hospital Federal ministers will meet in
Montreal Sunday night for a cabinet
Retreat ahead of parliament Rec
convening later this month one of the
issues topping the agenda will be
healthc care with many hospitals
overwhelmed and patients facing long
delays our Eric Sorenson spoke with the
minister in charge of Canada's Health
Care System
Eric Jeff in spite of what Canadians are
seeing in overcrowded emergency rooms
the federal health Minister insists
changes are happening to make Canada's
healthare system better on this week's
edition of the West block Mark Holland
says billions of federal dollars
earmarked for the provinces a year ago
are transforming healthc care and that
more provinces will sign on to the
agreements in the next several weeks
you're seeing immediate results in these
bilateral announcements which are very
explicit about exactly what improvements
are going to happen to the Health Care
System you also are going to see annual
report cards so you can see how your
Province or your territory is doing
relative to the commitments that were
made and see that year-over-year
progress yet doctors say they and
Canadian patients are still not seeing
shorter wait times less less gridlock
with hospital beds or an increase in
staff doctors told us the political
leaders need to collaborate not just
with each other but with health
professionals to find Solutions we've
gotten very good at naming the problem
we've uh We've identified Solutions we
haven't been the greatest at
implementing those Solutions one
solution being pursued by Premier Doug
Ford and the Ontario government is more
private clinics for MRIs CT scans as
well as knee and hip surgeries the
federal health Minister says Ottawa will
ensure that two-tier healthc care does
not become part of the Canadian Health
System we're not going to allow that to
happen let me be very clear uh Canada
and Canadians um are deeply proud of
having a public health care System we
know that not only is it a deterioration
of care um to allow um to allow private
care to expand uh but it really has a
huge injurious impact on costs as well
it's way too expensive the Ontario
government insists the private clinics
will still be publicly funded patients
will use their health card not a credit
card but it's also clear that Ottawa
will be watching closely Jeff Eric
Sorenson in Ottawa thanks Eric and you
can watch Eric's full interview tomorrow
morning on the west block that's right
here on
global families in Atlantic Canada are
sounding the alarm over a change in
support programs for children who are
blind or visually impaired the Atlantic
province's special education Authority
is reducing service and relying more on
Virtual training as Vanessa Wright
reports families say the changes will
have devastating impacts on
students I don't have New Finland Pei
new Bruns with coming families from all
four Atlantic provinces are hoping the
power of numbers will change a decision
that they say leave devastating impacts
on their Blind and Visually Impaired
children I've not been able to engage my
kids since they changed the model they
have no interest in sitting in front of
a computer screen they spent years
during Co doing that at issue is a
change to the short-term programs
offered by the Atlantic province's
special education Authority also known
as absy the agency would offer one to
two week intensive training
interventions in Halifax for visually
impaired students that taught them life
skills like how to safely and
effectively cook clean and use public
transportation but absy says they've
adopted a new virtual model in a
statement to Global News a
representative for absy says it is
important to note that Services have not
been cut they've been adjusted to align
with inclusive education policies by
being offered in closer proximity to
Learners home communities that still
left parents with questions about the
logistics I mean it's just common sense
a low vision child sitting in front of a
screen trying to learn how to pour
boiling water for instance I mean can
you imagine that is inherently risky
visually impaired kayin Lloyd has been
enrolled in absy programs since he was
was born he's now a firste public
relations student at Mount St Vincent
University and worries the decision
won't set students up for Success what
absy has done is replaced in my opinion
one of if not the best Service delivery
models in North America with a watered
down poor excuse for services that is
inequitable for students who live in
rural areas together and talk to the
government and say that's not what we're
accepting a town hall in Halifax gave
families across the maritimes an
opportunity to express their concerns
hoping to catch the attention of the
provincial governments our kids are
being marginalized the province of Nova
Scotia has a mandate to be accessible
and inclusive by 20130 and abs is
actually moving backwards from that
Vanessa Wright Global News hallifax
Canada's capital in Crisis coming up how
the housing shortage is fueling the
opioid epidemic
Canada's opioid epidemic and housing
crisis are colliding the most recent
data shows nearly 4,000 Canadians died
during the first half of last year
that's more than 20 deaths per day the
devastation is plain to see in Canadian
cities where housing is Out Of Reach for
many teria isri joined a police patrol
in downtown Ottawa to see the challenges
up close Ottawa represents the height of
Canadian political power unconscious
having moved for 1.5 hours but you don't
have to look far to find the depths of
Canadian
despair a short ride from Parliament
Hills scenes like this one are not
uncommon okay let's go my dear pack it
up there Sergeant Avery Flanigan has
been called to this church many times
before so options that police can do I I
can arrest and I can charge for
possession of uh crack cocaine um am I
going to do that to an addict um with
that small amount no that's that's not
what we're down here to do Sergeant
Flanigan is part of the neighborhood
resource team with Ottawa Police he
knows every alley and every Alco see all
the needles here perhaps we'll come
across um a victim that's overdosed back
here and no one's even reported it
Sergeant Flanigan has been on the job
for 20 years the last few have been some
of the hardest but even before before
the pandemic I think North America was
hit with this opioid crisis mental
health and addiction calls take up most
of his day did you ever overdose on
fentanyl at all uh I've I've been uh
known to to overdose twice before or
three times twice or three times yeah
about three times like I don't really
know when I hit the floor you wake up
and you don't even know that you
overdose know you just think you're just
waking up really pretty scary feeling
yeah it's pretty scary feeling and
housing wise right now what's your
situation uh I live at the shelter but
some something this doal with my friends
Canada's opioid crisis runs parallel
with the housing crisis that Justin
what's going on everything good Justin
sleeps on the streets so there's all
sorts of vacant dwellings but they're
not being accessed for I don't know
financial reasons as opposed to
humanitarian uh assistance in 2017 the
Trudeau government pledged to cut
homelessness by 50% within the decade
we're now past the halfway mark and
there's no concrete evidence the
strategy is working I think it's an area
that we need to uh get better data we've
had um very serious challenges uh that
were related to data collection during
the covid-19 pandemic I haven't seen the
visibility of homelessness this bad this
Ottawa professor says it all comes back
to the housing crunch there has to be
resources targeting the deficiency uh in
Income Support things like rent
supplements we need a lot more of them
this man is one of the success uccess
stories he used to sleep at the
Salvation Army but eventually found
housing I've had mental health issues
and I've I've seek help and a lot of it
thank God the 61-year-old is back at the
shelter searching for his friend he's
gone missing about 5 months now and he's
usually either in jail or here Sergeant
Flanigan has also met people over the
years who have disappeared all I can do
is focus here in Ottawa and try to come
up with some ideas and small little
Band-Aids to to help help in a National
Emergency playing out in cities across
Canada teria isri Global News
Ottawa still ahead aerial Advantage the
new tool helping Alberta firefighters in
their Darkest
Hours after last year's record-breaking
Wildfire season Crews across western
Canada are now looking to new technology
to help in future fights warmer
temperatures that fuel fires during the
day often cool at night offering an
opportunity for firefighters to gain the
upper hand it's why Alberta has added a
new tool capable of tackling wildfires
from the air in the dark Heather yks
West
explains when fire threatened Edson
Alberta back in June Crews work to
protect the town day and night typically
overnight the uh humidity is higher and
the temperatures lower uh thus kind of
affecting the fire Behavior keeping it
low while Darkness gives firefighters
the upper hand it also often keeps
aircraft on the ground helicopters and
water bombers unable to see the
situation properly at night but not
anymore back in 2018 Vancouver's Talon
helicopters bought a dolphin Airbus
Chopper the type used by the US Coast
Guard and made it night vision ready all
the lighting in the interior and all
that has changed so it's um it's
compliant with using night vision
goggles um at at the time over the last
several years it's been used at Night by
BC search and rescue and BC ambulance it
was also piloted by BC wildfire in 2020
things went well with that um but uh
nothing nothing came of it over the next
uh next couple
years BC wildfire says it hasn't had
enough time to integrate the technology
into its
Fleet but one province's loss has been
another's gain Last Summer the
helicopter spent 115 nighttime hours
fighting wildfires across Alberta
typically we would go out um kind of
just before dusk uh get good situational
Awareness on a wildfire and then fly
through the night uh till about 3:00 or
4 in the morning Alberta Wildfire says
the helicopter was an inv valuable tool
through the record-breaking Fire season
of this past year but while Canada saw
more than 18 million hectares burned so
far Alberta is the only Canadian
jurisdiction using the air support able
to fly at night Heather YX West Global
News
Calgary a new spin on the wild west up
next the Calgary group using movies to
tackle old indigenous
stereotypes
welcome back western movies have a
storied history but many of those
classic films also portray an inaccurate
unflattering picture of indigenous
people well now a group of creatives in
Calgary is hoping to rewrite that
narrative Gil Tucker
explains images and action from long
ago paired up with the sounds of
today indigenous and non-indigenous
calgarians coming together with a new
take on the old
west the show's called Indians and
cowboys we flipped it around and we're
trying to retell the history what do you
know about treaty 7 a production by the
making treaty 7 cultural Society
featuring big screen scenes going back a
hundred years with live music and new
dialogue dubbed in but there's no word
in our language for surrender when you
watch these old westerns often the
indigenous people are the losers running
from a burning teepee waiting for a
white man to save them and so we're
flipping that whole
narrative we have white people dressed
up as natives wearing braids and bad
Buck skins and that's what we're making
fun
of they're just really silly when they
kind of depict what we're all about and
how we dance and I really get a kick out
of some of the scenes why don't you hop
in and mansplain all about this bounty
now the floodgates are open for all of
our tribes to tell our stories eh and
tell the correct
[Music]
story it's really good for our youth cuz
then it empowers
[Music]
them and even though this is kind of a
wacky project and there is a lot of
humor it's actually touching on a really
really important themes as well which is
like how are we going to get along from
this point forward I'm still trying to
figure out what surrender means and that
is the beauty finding voice for all
people that call this territory home in
an indigenously LED way and it's about
bringing people together and creating
conversations Gil talker Global
News and that is global national for
this Saturday night I'm Jeff simple
tonight's your Canada is the
Saskatchewan legislative building in
Regina thanks for watching calling
christe will be at the anchor desk with
you tomorrow have a great
night